ya hemos hablado en varios vídeos sobre
los tipos de mercado que podríamos ver
en economía en un extremo podrías tener
la competencia perfecta vamos a escribir
competencia perfecta y aquí es donde
tienes muchas empresas lo que producen
no está diferenciado no hay barreras a
la entrada y en esa situación hemos
observado que las empresas simplemente
tienen que tomar el precio de mercado y
ese precio de mercado va a describir
cuál será su ingreso marginal no importa
cuánto produzcan cada una de esas
empresas de forma individual sólo podrán
obtener el precio de mercado de modo que
el ingreso marginal será determinado por
ese precio pero luego analizamos las
empresas de competencia imperfecta
competencia imperfecta en el otro
extremo tenemos el monopolio donde sólo
hay una empresa en el mercado enormes
barreras a la entrada y por lo tanto esa
compañía o empresa es esencialmente el
mercado por lo que su curva de demanda
para su producto es esencialmente la
curva de demanda del mercado
y medio existen cosas como la
competencia monopolística por aquí y en
la competencia monopolística hay varias
empresas que compiten pero todas están
diferenciadas de alguna manera y existen
algunas barreras a la entrada un buen
ejemplo de competencia monopolística o
competencia imperfecta podría ser el
mercado de calzado deportivo en el
mercado de calzado deportivo tienes
varios competidores tiene es nike y
adidas reebok y podríamos seguir
diciendo nombres y todos ellos están
diferenciados a su manera todos tienen
sus propias marcas que han ido
construyendo con el tiempo tienen
asociaciones con ciertas figuras
deportivas los zapatos de algunas
empresas pueden percibirse como mejores
en ciertas categorías pero también están
compitiendo entre sí de modo que la
competencia por la que están disputando
entre sí se podría considerar una
competencia monopolística porque sólo
nike y puede vender zapatos nike
así que puedes imaginar una curva de
demanda solo de zapatos nike por lo que
en una competencia imperfecta
las empresas tienen su propia curva de
demanda única y su cantidad de
producción afectará el precio que
obtienen por el producto o el servicio y
lo que veremos en este vídeo será lo que
pasa cuando nos enfrentamos a la
competencia imperfecta su curva de
demanda y veremos que el precio no será
exactamente el ingreso marginal y para
entenderlo veamos un modelo simple de
modo que aquí tengo un modelo muy simple
de una curva de demanda para una empresa
en un mercado de competencia imperfecta
y pueden ver aquí que cuanto más
produzca esa empresa menor será el
precio que pueda obtener por ese bien y
podemos ver muy claramente que esto es
una clásica curva de demanda descendente
pero lo que es realmente interesante es
pensar en cuál será el ingreso marginal
especialmente el ingreso marginal en un
mundo donde si venden una unidad
obtienen 32.50 pero cuando venden dos
unidades no es como que obtendrán 32.50
por la primera de esas unidades y luego
obtendrán 25 por la segunda unidad
si tienes un precio de mercado de 25
pesos obtendrás 25 pesos en cada una de
las dos unidades así que aunque alguien
esté dispuesto a pagar 32.50 por una
solo pagará 25 pesos cuando haya dos así
que pensemos en lo que le hace al
ingreso marginal te animo a que a pausa
es el vídeo y trates de completar esta
tabla antes de que lo haga contigo muy
bien ahora hagámoslo juntos así que
nuestros ingresos totales obviamente
cuando no hemos vendido nada es igual a
cero ingresos totales
ahora cuando vendemos una unidad a 32.50
bueno entonces nuestro ingreso total
será de treinta y 2.50 no es una
sorpresa ahora se va a poner interesante
cuando vendamos dos unidades cuál será
nuestro ingreso total bueno ambas
unidades se venderán a 25 pesos no es
como acabo de decir como si la primera
persona todavía estuviera dispuesta a
pagar 32.50 oye ahora su precio de
mercado es de 25 pesos eso
que todos van a pagar así que ahora tu
ingreso total será de 50 pesos dos veces
25 pesos ahora cuando llegas a 3 el
precio de mercado que puedes obtener es
17.50 veamos que será 52.50 52.50 de
ingresos totales y luego si tu precio de
mercado fuera de 10 pesos podrías
obtener una cantidad de 4 si deseas
vender 4 puedes hacerlo a un precio de
10 pesos
puedes hacerlo de cualquier manera pero
tu ingreso total será de 40 pesos ahora
a partir de esto podemos pensar bueno
cuál es nuestro ingreso marginal bueno
nuestro ingreso marginal para esa
primera unidad es el mismo que el precio
de esa primera unidad pasamos de 0 a 30
y 2.50 con esa primera unidad por lo que
aquí es 32.50 pero qué hay de la primera
unidad a esta segunda unidad bueno
nuestras unidades aumentan en 1 pero
nuestros ingresos de 3
y 2.50 a 50 aumentan en 17.50 por lo que
ya estamos viendo que existe una
discrepancia en nuestros ingresos
marginales y nuestro precio y podemos
continuar cuando pasamos de 2 a 3
unidades
nuestros ingresos sólo aumentan en 2.50
por lo que ese será nuestro ingreso
marginal y luego sucede algo muy
interesante a medida que pasamos de 3 a
4 unidades
nuestros ingresos totales en realidad
disminuyen disminuyen en 12.50 menos
12.50 justo aquí y eso se debe a que
cuando el precio es tan bajo estás
recibiendo un impacto en todas las
unidades que estás vendiendo por lo que
en realidad obtendrás un ingreso total
más bajo por aquí y si lo grafica mos
veremos muy claramente que la curva de
ingreso marginal parte de la curva de
demanda de la empresa que está en el
mercado de competencia imperfecta y
podemos ver que aquí en una unidad
nuestro ingreso marginal es el mismo
pero en dos unidades
nuestro ingreso marginal es de 17.50 en
tres unidades nuestro ingreso marginal
es de 2.50 y tenemos una curva de
ingreso marginal que se ve así de modo
que la gran conclusión es que una
empresa que opera en un mercado de
competencia imperfecta no es precio
aceptante no es que no importe cuanto
produzca porque vas a obtener el mismo
precio si no tendrá su propia curva de
demanda única porque hay una cierta
diferenciación en el mercado y por lo
tanto vas a tener una curva de demanda
con pendiente descendente y debido a esa
curva de demanda con pendiente
descendente también vas a tener una
curva de ingreso marginal con pendiente
descendente y esa curva de ingreso
marginal en realidad tendrá una
pendiente descendente a una tasa más
pronunciada por lo que cuando empecemos
a hacer el análisis del costo marginal
de la empresa y veamos donde se
intersecta con el ingreso marginal
recuerda si se trata de una empresa que
opera en un mercado de competencia
perfecta la curva de ingreso marginal es
horizon
pero cuando pensamos en esa curva de
ingreso marginal para una empresa en un
mercado de competencia imperfecta va a
tener una pendiente descendente va a
tener una pendiente más descendente que
su curva de demanda nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo